today on the matt well show the white
house calls for big tech companies to
censor so-called hate speech but what is
hate speech and should we be censoring
it at all we'll talk about that also
five headlines including
governor desantis's effort to rein in
big tech speaking of big tech and a
maryland school district's efforts to
instill anti-racism in preschoolers
plus our daily cancellation and much
more today on the matt walsh show
you know i don't quite hate myself
enough to waste my time watching white
house press briefings i do catch the
highlights sometimes though
there was a highlight from the press
conference on monday
that perhaps deserves our attention one
member of our illustrious press
always looking to ask the tough
questions to hold those in power
accountable to shine the light of truth
into the darkest corners democracy dies
in darkness after all
they took the time to ask white house
press secretary jen saki whether
it's nice to not have trump around
anymore really tough question
always the tough questions from this
bunch but there was something said in
that exchange that was
inadvertently interesting and important
so let's take a listen
as you know president trump has been
barred from a lot of social media sites
it's curious whether you think his
absence has made your job any easier or
the white house's job any easier as it
kind of
goes forward on these coveted
negotiations in what way
he created a lot of noise right he he
would have certain gravitational pull
with republicans who may be
um maybe more inclined to take a harder
position
i wonder if that's anything that you
guys have thought about or
kind of considered this may be hard to
believe we don't spend a lot of time
talking about our thinking about
president trump here former president
trump
to be very clear i think that's a
question that's probably more
appropriate for
republican members who are looking for
ways to
support a bipartisan package and whether
that gives them space but i can't say we
miss him on twitter
does president by the support the
continuing ban of president trump on
their sites
i think that's a decision made by
twitter we've certainly spoken to and
he's spoken to
the need for social media platforms to
continue to take steps to
reduce hate speech but we don't have
more for you on it than that
yeah that's not true first of all the
idea that they don't spend a lot of time
thinking about donald trump they spent a
lot of time thinking about donald trump
i mean
they you know he he joe biden
issues 14 executive orders every day to
undo trump's policies
and has said that that's what he's doing
so i think they do spend a lot of time
thinking about him
but that's not the point they say
continue to take steps to reduce hate
speech
the implication here obviously is that
by their thinking donald trump is guilty
of hate speech and his ban was a way of
reducing the hate speech
the implication is also though she says
it as an aside and moves on quickly and
of course there's no follow-up
that the administration is is pushing
the big tech companies to
purge and censor those who are guilty of
hate speech
no big surprise there but it does does
highlight why hate speech is so
dangerous and when i say hate speech is
dangerous i don't mean that the type of
speech
they call hate speech is dangerous i
mean the term is the term hate speech
the labeling of certain speech as hate
speech
especially when it's done by people in
power and for political reasons
is dangerous conservatives made a
massive mistake i think not the first by
a long shot
when many of them tacitly went along
with the formation of categories like
hate speech and even hate crime the
difference between
those two hate speech and hate crime is
that hate crime is an actual legal
category though
it shouldn't be it is while hate speech
is not but not for lack of trying
i mean the left has long wanted to make
hate speech a crime
in its own right they've so far run into
roadblocks mostly from the supreme court
preventing them from achieving that goal
but they're going to keep trying
even so other powerful institutions
outside of the court system
namely big tech also academia have
adopted their own policies of punishing
so-called hate speech and ultimately
this is an excuse
a cover a trojan horse by which
conservative speech and thought
and really any speech or thought that
does not comport with leftist orthodoxy
is silenced and i i think it's therefore
worth analyzing
[Music]
this idea of hate speech and the main
thing we should say
in analyzing it is that it doesn't
really exist or at least
it doesn't exist in any sort of
objective way
because to label something hate speech
just as to label a crime a hate crime
is to label not the thing itself but the
motivations
behind it so you hear someone say
something and you call it hate speech
because according to you it was said for
hateful reasons
but you of course have no way of knowing
that unless the speech in question was
someone literally saying i hate you
almost anything outside of that or many
many of the things outside of that when
you call it hate speech
you are merely labeling your own
feelings about
someone else's speech so it reminds me
of uh of the scene in the office when
someone poops on
michael's carpet and he calls it a hate
crime
and which it very well may have been but
stanley says oh it's not a hate crime
and michael says well i hated it
that is essentially how both hate speech
and hate crimes are judged
the person doing the labeling is using
the standard of their own
feelings about the speech or the act in
question
for the feelings of the person who
actually said or did the thing
nobody but that person really knows
this is why the hate speech label has
always been and always will be political
the left
hates conservative speech and labels it
hate speech which is a statement not
about the speech
but about their perspective of the
speech
they feel that the speech is uh
motivated by hatred whether or not it
actually is
how could they possibly know unless
you're inside the mind and the heart of
the person doing the speaking
besides even if speech is motivated by
hate
who is to say that that's a bad thing
necessarily yes i will say this right
now
sometimes hate speech is good there are
plenty of things in the world
worthy of hatred you may express your
views about those things and in so doing
you are speaking
at least part partly out of hate so in a
literal sense it is hate speech
it is hateful speech um
i get hit with a speech with the hate
speech label all the time
and often i must admit quite accurately
for example recently i said something on
this show as i have many times in the
past about drag queen story hours
and i'm against them if you haven't
heard and i was afterwards accused of
hate speech
as usual not the first time for that and
yeah you know
you're right i do hate drag queen story
hours
i absolutely hate it it is hateful
speech i absolutely hate them
and uh if you picked up on that i'm glad
because that was the message i was
trying to send
i hate the sexual exploitation of
children
call me crazy i just hate it hate speech
sure i guess so
now if by calling it hate speech you
mean to accuse me of hating the actual
people themselves who host and stage
these drag shows for children well again
you're not far off the mark i mean i i
try not to hate any individual person
hate the sin
uh not the sinner um is uh
but because i am a christian we are
commanded not to
hate people but i will admit that i fail
to live up to that edict sometimes and
yes i lapse into
actually hating the individual people
who
sexually exploit children i i will admit
that
but what about the bad kind of hate that
certainly exists
just as with hate crimes you know i
don't i don't think the hate crime
label the hate crime label should exist
but the things that are
legally labeled hate crimes are of
course very bad
physically attacking someone for their
race or ethnicity for example
that's hateful yeah it's obviously bad
you should go to jail for it
there is speech that is hateful in a bad
way
though it isn't a crime and should not
be it's still worthy of our condemnation
i myself am the target of quite a lot of
deeply hateful speech
often i know it's hateful because the
person will say something to me like i
hate you and want you to die
kill yourself you know that sort of
thing okay i think i think i'm safe in
assuming
that's that's hateful they hate me
but the implication is that really
hateful speech
is the worst kind of speech just as
we're supposed to believe that
really hateful crime is the worst kind
of crime
the person who physically assaults
another person for their race will get a
harsher penalty
than someone who physically assaults
another person out of say greed because
he wants their money or
just out of general indifference just
for the fun of it
but i think this is wrong crime
motivated by hate
is is bad is it worse
than crime motivated by indifference or
greed or
envy i don't see why that's the case i
mean at a minimum they're all
equally as evil but really it seems to
me people who commit
violent crimes indifferently are the
worst of all they're the worst of the
worst they're the most dangerous
if anything indifferent crimes should
get the get the kind of emphasis that
hate crimes do
think about serial killers sociopaths
school shooters most of these
indifferent they're committing violent
crime indifferently
they don't hate the people they're
victimizing they don't feel anything to
those towards those people
that's the problem and they are the most
dangerous same thing with speech
uh people who say really hateful things
are bad
or maybe i should say people who hate
things that should not be hated
but what makes what makes the internet
especially miserable
are the trolls who say vile and horrible
things indifferently
merely to get a rise out of people or to
experience whatever
thrill they get out of it which i don't
quite understand but they get some kind
of thrill
that's the problem with hate speech it's
an obscure category
it doesn't really mean anything and even
if it does mean something it doesn't
deserve the attention we give it
but this is all academic none of this
matters to the left of course
they're not worried about hate per se
they're worried about the ideas
they hate and this is their way of
shutting all of that down let's get now
to our five headlines
[Music]
okay this is from the new york post says
florida governor ron desantis launched
an offensive against big tech on tuesday
warning that the social media platforms
are targeting politicians like former
president donald trump now
but will soon be coming for regular
american citizens vowing to combat the
threat
he said in a news conference quote today
they may come after someone who looks
like me tomorrow they come after someone
who looks like you
as he was announcing the transparency
and technology act
as part of his measure desantis
suggested fines of a hundred thousand
dollars per day for de-platforming
political candidates
as well as daily fines for any company
that quote uses their content and
user-related algorithms to suppress or
prioritize the access of any content
related to a political candidate
or cause on the ballot the governor also
called for allowing people to opt
out of content algorithms requiring
notification about changes in terms of
service
and providing the right of citizens to
take legal action if these conditions
are violated
all of this is great this is all exactly
what
republicans republicans should have done
this
years ago on the federal level and they
could have at least tried they didn't
even try
trump didn't try none of them tried when
they had the chance this is exactly what
needs to happen
um and some of this should be totally
uncontroversial
so yeah if you want to we we could have
a debate about
um rules that stop politic uh
social media companies from censoring
political political content or political
candidates
uh i think there should be those rules
but something like um
notification about changes in terms of
service
yeah that's just that is basic
transparency that we expect and legally
require
of most any other company
and oftentimes companies that don't have
nearly the kind of of power and control
over you that big tech companies do
that's all that is what's the argument
against it
you know if if they're gonna if they're
gonna make a change
at a minimum if they're gonna make a
change to the terms of service
um you know you you signed up for the
site thinking one thing
and then they start tinkering with it
and changing it they should have to tell
you that
and again at a minimum if twitter wants
to decide
that it's going to start purging
conservative accounts as they have been
doing which is why all conservatives are
losing their twitter followers
they should at a minimum have to tell us
that they're doing it and
explain why basic transparency
that we require of any other company
um desantis we'll play some of the clips
from this because i i just think it's
it's great he uh
here he is talking about some of the
things that prompted this
and uh discussing what twitter did with
the new york post story
and how that's motivating some of of
what he's doing now let's watch
hunter biden's story was true okay we
now know was true
and the typical corporate media outlets
they just chose to ignore it
obviously they wanted to beat trump they
had a they had a view on the election
they didn't want to give it any air so
we rely on social media
to go around that not let
corporate legacy media outlets control
the discourse and let us speak
so you had the new york post to run it
and you couldn't get any traction you
couldn't get any reach on it
because big tech put their thumb on the
scale so that was true what they said at
the time
oh it was it was it's a conspiracy or
it's based on
on on hacked information are you kidding
me
you're trying to tell me if there was
hacked information that could damage me
you guys wouldn't print it give me a
break you can whiz on my leg but don't
tell me it's raining
you guys would print it every single day
if you could and big tech would allow it
to proliferate
every single day 20 24 7. so it's not
being done in a principled basis
and it's not there's there's threats on
me
and it only gets taken down if law
enforcement goes and tells
tells them to do it otherwise it just
stays up they're not moderating any of
that
oh he's absolutely right and if um
once again twitter wants to shut down
the new york post story
and yes that is that is influencing the
election
now maybe you could argue that it
wouldn't be influencing the election
quite as much at least not influencing
it in a dishonest way
if twitter just came out and said
listen we are we're a liberal company
we're a left-wing company this is how we
this is how we run things
we're not interested in conservative
content uh the the content that we're
gonna highlight and put in front of your
eyes
that's gonna be left-wing content and if
there's a story that we don't like for
political reasons we're gonna get rid of
it
at least if they came out and said that
then everyone would know where they
stand and the bias would maybe be a
little bit less harmful
that's why i tend to think that bias
from you know a
from a a news organization like cnn if
we can call them a news organization but
the bias from cnn is is is a
it's indefensible but it's also not very
harmful because everybody knows what
they're getting with cnn
even if they don't admit it still
everyone knows
now with twitter there are still a lot
of people who use twitter and are
oblivious to this
they think they're getting an reflection
you know they
the way they what they think is
happening is that when they go to their
news feed on twitter or facebook
that they're going to be exposed to news
and they're going to find out what's
going on
it's what most people think
so twitter should have to be honest
about that
and uh here's desantis touching on
something that i that i also feel i mean
we we talk about the
the bias from twitter
which is very concerning but that
doesn't even hold a candle to what
happened to parlor
uh let's listen to santos on that what
really i think
scared me was the decapitation of parlor
it wasn't just
it wasn't just some of that stuff it was
the web hosting
the payment processing take away your
email your text
you could totally neuter a candidate's
ability to communicate and execute a
campaign plan
so once we have that that situation uh
they can't de-platform you
without consequence and look i don't
know that there has been
in 2020 we'd have to look i don't know
that there has been a candidate that got
wiped off the map but you see the way
this
is going and i think that protection is
very well
well warranted and i think it should be
there and
just think if you're in october of 2022
and you have a state senate race or
something
and they do platform one of the two
candidates that is not that's going to
have a huge impact
on the outcome of the race yeah
parlor they they we could talk about the
bias from twitter and facebook
as i said that's bad enough but what
they did with parlor
they just came in and he says
decapitated good word for it
this came in and wiped it out they
didn't like parlor said no you can't
have that
for years we were told oh if you if you
want uh if you want this
if you want your own kind of social
media platform then go set up your own
social media platform
all right we won't bother you over there
that isn't that always the the
trajectory isn't that always the theme
with the left but they said
no we we won't bother you just just keep
it to yourself
keep it in private and uh and and that's
fine we won't bother you
and so people went to parliament and
they said fine well we'll start our own
thing we're gonna go over here to parlor
and enough people went over there
and then the left said no never mind you
can't have that either
yeah it is it is time for legislative
solutions to this problem so i'm glad
that desantis is getting the ball
rolling
and i say again ron desantis 2024 he's
my definitely my early friend
number two the new york times has an
article um the headline is
how the biden administration can help
solve our reality
crisis we have a reality crisis
and among other things it is suggested
i'm not this not satire not making this
up it suggested that biden appoint a
quote
reality czar a czar of reality
lord of all reality i thought that was
my job
um the writer says several experts i
spoke with recommend that
the bible administration put together a
cross-agency task force
to tackle disinformation and domestic
extremism
which would be led by something like a
reality czar
it sounds a little dystopian i'll grant
but let's hear them out
right now these experts said the federal
government's response to disinformation
domestic extremism
is haphazard and spread across multiple
agencies and there's a lot of
unnecessary overlap
and uh and the way to solve that i'm not
gonna read all this but the way to solve
that
is to have an agency and an actual czar
who's i
i guess now i did read all of this
and um before going on the air
you know it's not quite explained what
exactly the realities are
would do um but i guess the idea is that
we have a czar we have an authority
figure
to stand up and tell us what reality is
that just
they they are the official authority if
there's information circulating they can
declare
if it's false or not and you think this
is so absurd
now this this this this couldn't happen
and even if it did happen
who who would actually listen to the
realities are
a lot of people you look at these
organizations that have just
declared themselves fact checkers
they haven't had to prove why they
deserve that label or anything like that
organization comes along and says oh
we're fact checkers it's what we do
and so if we say it's not a fact because
we're fact checkers means it's not
many people fall for that so i'm sure
the realities are
all we need is the realities of the you
know we know the on the left
they believe in pregnant men uh for
example so we just need the realities
are to come out and say yes officially
this is reality men can get pregnant the
realities are has spoken
it is settled law
number three a cnn legal analyst reacted
to trump's impeachment defense
and she made a rather startling legal
claim
let's listen so let me start with you
this is the 14-page brief filed by the
president's lawyers
it says number one this is
unconstitutional because he is a former
president it says number two
that he has a first amendment right to
speak and therefore he said things at a
rally and people attack the capital
you can't hold him accountable yeah
those are wrong
and they're well countered by the very
long brief the house filed earlier today
i mean you don't have a first amendment
right to lie you don't have a first
amendment right to
put people in danger and he did both of
those things
and of course we know the jurisdictional
arguments were covered in about 40 pages
of the house's brief as well
so you know it's not surprising that in
only 36 hours with what
are clearly not his a-listers of defense
lawyers they weren't able to come up
with compelling arguments
but it also highlights that there really
aren't any compelling defense arguments
here at all so
you know the brief was mostly what was
to be expected there was one thing
actually that did surprise that's a
legal analyst
she's and she's a lecturer i didn't see
the body was it
columbia law school elect
lecturer columbia law school legal
analyst a lecturer
and her claim is that you don't have a
first amendment right to lie
uh yes you do see i'm not i'm not a
legal lecturer at all
i don't have any job in any law school i
didn't go to law school
but i can say you absolutely have a
first amendment right to lie
that is but keep in mind we talked about
hate speech to begin the show
these are the same people who would who
according to them what they would like
to see happen is that you don't have a
first amendment right to say things
hatefully either
who decides if it's hateful they do who
decides if it's a lie
they do all right number four the
montgomery from the daily wire the
montgomery county public school district
of maryland spent more than
40 um 450 000 on an anti-racist audit
for the 2020 through 2021 school year
which resulted in the district
tentatively adopting policies that push
anti-racist thinking in preschool
so we're talking about like three and
four-year-olds okay according to a copy
of the school district's tentative
action policy obtained by the daily wire
the district will now provide a
culturally responsive pre-kindergarten
to grade 12 curriculum
that promotes equity respect anti-racist
thinking
and civility the i'm wondering
which which when do we get to the how to
riot
part of the lesson is that in the
civility how to riot civilly
the curriculum will also teach students
that the impact of racism on mental
health has been deemed a public health
crisis
the school district which is one of the
largest in the nation announced in
november that it would partner with the
mid-atlantic equity consortium for the
454 thousand dollars to conduct an
anti-racist audit
the audit was designed to examine the
district's systems practices and
policies that do not create access
opportunities and equitable outcomes for
every student's academic and social
emotional
uh well-being yeah starting and starting
in pre-k
now you know what i'm going to say
because what i always say when we read a
story like this which is for the first
thing is get your kids out of the public
school system
but i would add a you know an addendum
to that
and i would say this at least
at least get them out of the public
school system at these very early ages
please dear god do not send your
four-year-old to a public school system
now you homeschool them early on
send them to high school or something
maybe you know maybe that's a feasible
plan
because at that point if your kid's 13
or 14 they've been ra
you've raised them correctly and you've
um
maybe at that point they'll have the the
fortitude
and the formation to withstand the
brainwashing that will still happen
but the point is at four years old
forget about it
four years old there's there's just no
chance
you send your four-year-old in a
four-year-old is going to believe
whatever they are told it doesn't matter
what it is
you you anything you tell them you tell
them that you you you rode to work this
morning on a unicorn
they'll totally believe it they won't
even that won't even occur to them as an
odd thing to say
because talk about reality they have no
concept of reality
so when you send much more than than
this is the case with with the older
kids with younger kids when you send
your younger kid
to school that is an act of
profound trust you are putting
so much trust
in the people that will be in charge of
your child at that school
because the the influence and power
they're going to have over your child
it's
difficult to articulate the immensity of
it
and if they decide that they want to
brainwash your kid at the age of four
into this anti-racist nonsense into
critical race theory
that's it your child's gonna be
brainwashed there's almost nothing you
can do about it
if they're being exposed to that for
hours a day at that age
so please think twice about that i beg
of you
number five big news yesterday one of
the great crimes of the century somebody
changed the hollywood sign to read
holly boob um they someone climbed up
there and they changed the w
and the d and they made it uh and and
they they made it say boob
okay now that was the story yesterday
someone changed the hollywood sign made
it holly boob
um and of course i i
i think all people are intermittent
middle schoolers are delighted by
this story but now the new york post has
the latest and we're told that
because the new york post reports julia
rose who won fame for flashing her
breasts on live tv during the 2019 world
series apparently that's something you
can
win fame for now i've never heard of
this person but she's famous for this
um she was busted along with five others
for changing the famous hollywood sign
to read holly boob
she's a 27 year old model and apparently
this was done
in an act of protest because uh
she was protesting that instagram had
locked her out of her account
for posting nude photos
and i have to say this is a very
disappointing reveal
isn't it i i heard this story about the
hollywood boob thing
and i hoped that these were some very
industrious 12 year olds
who had who had managed like instead of
writing it on the bathroom stall
like the rest of us had done they had
they had big dreams i mean they they
went for it all
and that would have been impressive but
then you find out it's
27 year old they did it for instagram
and you know they did it for social
media clout
not fun at all i this is this is one of
the most disappointing endings i think
i've ever
seen uh in any story at all so that's
that's pretty bad all right we're gonna
move on now now
i am um before we get to our deal this
is usually when we get to our daily
cancellation but before we do that
this is pretty exciting i am debuting a
new segment on the show today
um and this will be a segment i figure
you know
one thing that i'd like to bring back
into the show that i used to have early
on and hasn't been as much
is a little bit of viewer feedback a
little bit of interaction with the the
viewers and the listeners
and so what i'm going to start doing
after the headlines every day
is reading they say you're not supposed
to read your comments especially on
youtube
talk about hatefulness right don't don't
read the comments is what everyone says
but the dirty little secret about people
in my position anyone with a platform is
that we all read the comments we always
do
we're not supposed to say that because
that only empowers the trolls because
they know that we will see the stuff
they're writing
yeah we do see it and it also hurts our
feelings we cry about it we do
so think about that next time um
so i'm gonna i'm gonna read a few of the
comments from the show on youtube
yesterday
just to get a little bit of the viewer
interaction and this is a segment that i
will call
reading the comments
creative i know this is from anthony
says i live across the street from that
mattress store in kenosha
i watch that mattress store crumble and
collapse into the road from the extreme
heat
i could feel from my front yard it
basically melted the brick building
it rained fire embers that night from
the entire block burning
i thought it was a real possibility i
could die that night i also know the
people and politicians responsible for
inciting the 20 million dollars in
damages to my city and neighborhood
will have to answer for what they did
because god never forgets i want to feel
bad for aoc but i don't
now she slightly knows how i and so many
kenoshans feel about the night my life
changed forever
we are still cleaning up the buildings
which were burnt i currently live in a
construction where i am reminded every
day what happened
um what happens for a man who was a
rapist and a thief evading police and
evading the responsibility for his
actions
uh this is this is why you should read
the comment because that's a great
comment
and these people like anthony completely
forgotten
have we gotten any have there really
been any follow-ups
with the people like anthony people in
the community
who lived in these neighborhoods that
were reduced to rubble
it i'm interested to know that's why i'm
glad to hear from anthony
i'm interested to know what it's like to
live in a neighborhood like that how are
things going
the media just completely ignores
they've been erased
nick says beard's looking thick matt
t-h-i-c-c-c
i don't really know what thick means
i've always thought it had a vaguely
sexual connotation i hope not given that
this came from someone named nick but
thank you nick uh miss region rat says
okay this groundhog thing being so old
school is actually really adorable
what a bunch of goofs i did come out
against the the groundhog day yesterday
and i had time to
because my problem with it is that as i
said we've gotten rid of all of our
cultural traditions pretty much all of
our shared traditions are out the window
you know thanksgiving everything's
everything's going the one thing we hold
on to
is the tradition where guys and top hats
talk to a magical rodent who can tell
the future
and i just think that's the one we keep
but as i had more time to reflect on
groundhog day i realized well
okay if that's all we got then i guess
we should i guess i should have the
opposite
attitude that we need to cling on to
groundhogs it's our last cultural
tradition it's all we have now
is this stupid rodent so i think you're
right diana
um rg reacting to
aoc's instagram where she was crying
about her trauma from the from the
writing she
uh rg says um omg what happened to
politicians
teddy roosevelt was shot in the chest
and still managed to give a speech
babies everywhere my god yeah that was
that's i covered that in a daily
cancellation i think recently
you look at he teddy roosevelt this is
quite literally was shot in the chest
and still gave a speech compare that to
politicians today
and what does that tell you um and david
says matt sounds like you're supporting
this gradual acceptance of the democrats
view
when you and others say well this is
what we can expect and
be ready for these changes how about a
plan to stop this
you're baptizing us slowly the dem put
their deranged opinions in our face
it's time to spin this around no this is
not this is not defeatism on my part
when i say well this is what this is
what we're going to expect this is
what's this is what's going to happen
um it's not defeatism it's about
you know i'm just like the realities are
wants us to
it's about facing reality and
i think especially in recent months
conservatives spent
there was a this kind of mass delusion
that took hold of conservatives and not
just in the last
few months but especially in the last
few months leading up to the
inauguration
where conservatives were refusing to
face reality and insisting to the very
end i mean
i don't know how many but many insisting
to the very end oh no
trump will still be in office there's no
way this is going to happen
and anyone like myself who said no look
it's he
joe biden's going to be president we
were castigated for it
no it's this we're not and we were
accused of being defeatist
i heard this many times if i said you
know joe biden's be present oh you're
being a defeatist
no i'm just i'm being a realist he will
be
i don't like it but he will be
so when i say things like that it's all
about facing reality
because we have to first if we want to
do anything about
what our reality is right now if we want
to change if we want to make changes in
reality
then we have to first face face it right
that's to be the first step
all right those are the comments for
today you know whether you're in school
or out of school whether you went to
college or you didn't whatever your
education level is
um the point is that all of us
throughout our whole lives we need to
strive to
know more information to gain more
knowledge the thing is you know
it doesn't matter what your your level
of of of
official education is if you stop
learning if you stop pursuing knowledge
the moment you get out of school
at whatever age that happens to be um
you you know you are not going
to be the the smart well-rounded person
that you could be because this has to be
a
a constant process of recharging
ourselves with new information and more
knowledge and that's why
you've got to check out the great
courses plus um
i just watched the great courses plus
course on world war ii the pacific
theater
they've got many history courses i i
tend to
uh to kind of prefer the history courses
but it's not just history with great
courses plus you get unlimited streaming
access to thousands of video lectures on
virtually anything that interests you
i mean really anything if you want to
learn tai chi or public speaking
if you want to know marine biology which
also i'm i'm interested in
if you want to know how to how to read
body language that could be an important
thing
then you got to check out great courses
plus great courses plus has something
for everyone and it's all thoroughly
vetted
fact-based information you know you can
trust from some of the best professors
and top experts in their field all over
the world
and when you download the great courses
plus app you can watch or listen on any
device
learn anytime anywhere uh it's also it's
also good in my experience i've been a
great courses fan for a long time
i also you know i like to read as well
but what i find is
sometimes especially at night when i
have time
[Music]
to either read or or watch a great
courses course
it can be easier sometimes to go with
the great courses
it's just kind of you could sit down and
relax and you could watch great courses
and it's just enjoyable it's fascinating
enjoyable you've got to check it out
what purpose waits for you sign up for
the great courses plus to find out i
have a special url to use
thegreatcoursesplus.com
walsh and that's
thegreatcoursesplus.comwalsh you get a
full month of unlimited access for free
don't miss out on this trust me again
that's thegreatcoursesplus.com
walsh another thing not to miss out on
um
when you still have a chance to take
advantage of this over the daily wire
become a daily wire member today use
promo code rhf to get 25
off that's rhf for 25 rhf obviously
refers to
um our new feature film run hide fight
and if you are one of the people that
has not had a chance to check out this
movie then what are you doing with your
life what are you doing with your time
you're wasting it all damn you go become
a daily wire member now and you can
watch
run hide fight uh which is a tense
suspenseful
exciting action-packed movie with a
great message but as we've been telling
you it's not you know
it's it's not a message movie where
we're trying to
sermonize to you it's really it's a it's
a movie it's entertainment
but also there's a good message as well
you can watch it over at dailywire.com
or on our mobile app or on our streaming
apps
at apple tv and roku if you're not a
daily wire member yet use promo code rhf
to get 25 off again rhf for 25
off let's get out to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we must
begin by discussing
the drama of a woman who has been dubbed
courtside karen
her real name in fact is juliana carlos
she's apparently an instagram influencer
which as far as i can tell just means
that she's married to a rich guy
and posts a lot of pictures of herself
online that makes her an influencer now
mrs carlos was at the uh the hawks game
couple nights ago courtside seats with
her husband
watching the home team take on lebron's
lakers at some point during the game
a brief argument or shouting match of
some kind broke out between lebron
and the husband of uh giuliana carlos
she after the fact described the
interaction
between herself because she intervened
she says
and she described the inner interaction
with lebron in a way that
certainly does not engender any sympathy
for her let's uh take a listen
so i'm minding my own business and chris
has been
a hawks fan forever he's been watching
the games for 10 years whatever he has
this issue with lebron i don't have an
issue
with lebron i don't give a [ __ ] about
lebron anyway
i'm minding my own business drinking
having fun
all of a sudden lebron says something to
my husband and i
and i see this and i go i stand up and
go don't [ __ ] talk to my husband and
he looks at me and he goes
sit the [ __ ] down should i go don't
[ __ ] call me
do you sit the f get the [ __ ] out of
here and i go don't [ __ ] talk to my
husband like that
don't talk to my husband and he
literally was like [ __ ] you
sit down and all of a sudden now i'm
getting kicked out excuse me i have
courtside seats that i pay for
[ __ ] you lebron you're [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out of here you're going to let a
25 year old girl intimidate you during a
game
bye i want to send that to our to our
editors i know it's probably fun for
them to
get all the my lord wha
why do rich guys marry women like this
now i
i know why they do i'm not naive but but
is it worth it
is it worth the price of listening to
that every day is it really
i assume i don't know anything about her
husband i assume he's older you know i
assume he's like 92.
um and your final years of life this is
what you're listening to
is it worth it to you in any case this
woman
um later apologized for the argument and
took full responsibility which
tells me you know which which does make
me doubt the part of the story where she
allegedly was called the b word uh she
seems to have backed away from that
and is now trying to apologize and move
on whatever actually happened
given what we know already about lebron
james and given what we know about this
woman just from the 30-second clip there
it's safe to say that there were no good
guys in the dispute no no one to root
for
but today's daily cancellation has
nothing to do with any of that
lebron james after the game didn't have
much to say about
the whole incident except this he
tweeted courtside karen
was mad mad followed by a bunch of
laughing emojis
i've already canceled grow men grown men
who use emojis so we're not going to
rehash that aspect of it
my issue today is with the pejorative
use of the name karen
okay that's what i'm canceling the care
and mean is officially canceled because
it's a racial slur
now to reiterate i'm not defending the
woman
who seems to embody pretty much all of
the things i loathe
also i'm not personally offended by the
karen thing i'm not a white woman
though i could become one if i wanted to
of course at least that's what i'm told
anyway
so for now it does it does it doesn't
concern me directly or apply to me but
i am a fan of intellectual consistency
and i do hate
with a burning unyielding passion hear
some hate speech
i hate double standards hate them
and on that basis i object to the name
karen being used in this way
now a couple things to establish here
first of all
karen does absolutely have
a racial connotation please do not
embarrass yourself by claiming otherwise
yes sometimes rarely but sometimes
non-white people are labeled karen's
but in its origination and in its most
popular usage it refers specifically to
obnoxious white women
and when a non-white woman is called a
karen the insult is
you're acting like a white woman okay
a time magazine article in july says
that the karen meme confronts the
violent history of white womanhood
a teen vogue article from around the
same time says that the archetypal karen
is a white woman
and that the karen meme originated quote
as an inside joke within communities of
color
that is it's an insult against white
woman and it was created by non-white
people
um in fact teen vogue the teen vogue
article takes issue with white women
using the word themselves in reference
to each other the writer
malavika cannon explains that non-white
people
have a right to use this slur against
white people and if you as a white
person use it yourself
then you are appropriating your own slur
and you can't do that
a daily beast article from earlier this
month says that um
says quote karen like the once popular
phrase becky
became a moniker to describe white women
who were problematic
in this case the author wishes to stop
using the term but not because it's
racist
um he he wants he wants to stop using
because he fears instead that
karens are being normalized by the use
of the word karen
and if you prefer to go to wic to go to
wikipedia for all your information
as most of uh the country does here's
what that site says about the origins of
karen it says quote
there are several possible origins of
the term one theory is that it's a
it's a an evolution of an
african-american vernacular english term
of referring to unreasonable white women
the term may have originated on black
twitter as a mean as a meme used to
describe
white women who tattle on black kids
lemonade stands
[ __ ] magazine that's the name of a
magazine don't blame me
described it as a term that originated
with black women but was co-opted by
white men
okay so again just get the irony here
this is a
a um pejorative
of a certain race of white people
and but white people aren't allowed to
use it
so that's that's offensive for us to use
it the point here is that
without any doubt at all this is a
racial term
the people who first came up with it and
first started using it
say that it's racial and they very much
object to any attempt to de-racialize it
the next question then is whether it is
a you know it is a racial term
but is it a racist term is it a racial
slur
well to answer that question we need
only engage in a thought experiment
very simple let us imagine an exactly
analogous situation
what if white people on twitter started
started to refer to obnoxious black
women using a stereotypical black woman
name
now in order to properly frame this
let's use an actual name as an example
abc news has an article from a few years
ago
listing what they call the top 20
whitest and blackest names
now if you have a problem with a phrase
like whitest and blackest names take it
up with abc news
one of the names at the top of their
list for black women is chinese
okay i'll take that as an example what
if white people on twitter a bunch of a
bunch of dastardly
right-wing white people let's say
started describing their encounters with
black women by saying things like oh man
so this chinese was up in my face etc
etc etc
would there be any doubt about whether
that qualifies as racist
would anyone even dare suggest that it
isn't racist
i certainly wouldn't i mean in my mind
it would be absolutely 100
clear to me that using a stereotypical
black female name as a pejorative
to refer to black women i don't like is
extremely racist
everything about it is racist if that's
not racist then what could possibly be
racist you're taking a stereotypical
name for members of a certain race and
using it as a pejorative against them
what what could qualify as racist if
that doesn't
that's the stance i would have in the
case of chinese
and so would everybody else everyone
you me everyone we would all agree that
it's racist
everyone would and on the left
especially among the very people
defending the use of the term karen
well they would be apoplectic i mean
they they would be writing think pieces
with titles like
the chinese meme is an attack on black
womanhood so on and so forth
we all know it no reasonable person can
deny it
so does this kind of racial slur
so what that establishes is this is race
this is racial
and it's racist we've established those
two things i think
undeniably next question
does this kind of racial slur this kind
of dehumanizing degrading way of
referring to people of another race
does it suddenly become acceptable if
you apply it to white people
no objectively it doesn't
subjectively according to our culture
and the way the rules are now set up it
does
according to those rules it's impossible
to be racist against white people so
so karen is not racist i mean you could
run up to a white person call him a
white devil
spit in his face and set him on fire and
you still would not be racist
those are the rules now but i object to
those rules
and so should you if it's so obvious
which it is that karen originates as a
racial slur
and it's intended to be a racial slur
then why do so few white people even
white women object to it
why is it that on the few occasions when
i brought this issue up
i've been met with backlash mostly by
white people
desperately defending the slurs that are
used against them
taking it personally that i think they
shouldn't be slurred
the reason i think is that white people
have stockholm syndrome they think that
they aren't allowed to object to this
kind of thing they actually think they
might be racist if they object to racism
targeted at them
they're at the point now where you could
go up to them and pee in their cereal
and they would just smile and say hey
man no problem i understand
you know i would never tell you to stop
peeing in my cereal
i didn't want those frosted flakes
anyway um unless you want me to eat them
that's it but you know it would be
really obnoxious
on my part to object okay i i uh and if
i came up and said hey man that guy's
peeing in your cereal that's kind of
wrong maybe you shouldn't do that
you would say to me hey hey you
snowflake get out mind your business
stop being a drama queen
what is this cancel culture trying to
cancel this person for pee in my cereal
come on it's pathetic
i mean have a little self-respect for
god's sake
you don't have to accept double
standards you don't have to go along
with it
and you shouldn't now i i know that just
by pointing out a double standard that's
not enough to make it go away
i get it what's the other option to just
accept it to cooperate with it
no absolutely not
we should take the stance that racial
slurs are bad
no matter who they are applied to
and as it happens right now there's
really only
one racial slur i can think of that is
popularly
used and can be used without any social
consequence whatsoever and so
that should be the racial slur we focus
on because all the others everyone
agrees are bad
this one even the people who who fall
victim to it
cannot bring themselves to say that it's
bad
but it is and that is why the karen meme
and all who use it have been canceled
and we will leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
the senate prepares for the
pseudo-impeachment trial of former
president trump aoc compares ted cruz
and josh hawley to rapists
and blm gets nominated for a nobel peace
prize check it out on the michael knoll
[Music]
show
you